good morning Millennials Taylor just
[ __ ] coughs again and honestly like
I'm going to kill her don't make me
laugh cuz the Laughing triggers the
cough okay sorry well then we're in
trouble are you kidding me do not to
swallow it swallow your cough it is
juice good morning everyone welcome back
to another amazing premium episode of
the morning toast today is Tuesday
August 20 something Margo
21st this is the morning toast jackieo
is still gallivanting across the globe
but thank God thank God we have justice
Premium a host tell Shrek her joining us
for the second day in a row cuz one just
wasn't enough I was on Taylor showed
this morning this morning we did a great
segment part two part 2 just what I
thought we're oh yeah
but like I was just basically schooling
Taylor on all things important like she
was kind of on Carroll side and then I
had to like take her to school and then
also you were like kind of doubting
Kylie and her success so I really had to
take you to like high school in college
there's a yeah like elementary school
yeah Bethany Carol's elementary school
Kylie was college was grad school but
it's really good episode so go to toast
record calm or if you're a subscriber go
listen I was on yesterday two very deep
episode yesterday yes that'll be
available on the podcast or tomorrow um
tastes of Taylor like around like 1 p.m.
ok just talking about some stuff I've
never spoken about and that I'm really
uncomfortable speaking about but
literally the only person I would speak
to it about is Taylor like in a public
forum I feel so honored and like trusted
by the way yeah it was good it wasn't
it's good to talk about it it is and
look I hate when people like go through
public things and they're like trying
pretend like they didn't happen like cuz
it to happen
singing saga of 2006 she still never
discussed that no I know maybe she'll
talk about it on her new show or that
her you know she's married or in gated
to Diana Ross's son died like honestly
prestigious as hell I know and now they
have a show on E and by the way their
whole commercial was like in tune with
each other in tune with love in tune
with music and that's just further
furthers my theory that everyone any
news watches the morning shows because
we made like we always say in tune with
what
necessary stop and they're always just
like shave Ali like using our lingo in
their commentary and I actually got
confirmation from someone this weekend
that she had a meeting at E and she was
like by the way you guys know like the
morning shows right and they're like
yeah they're like you guys like like you
steal from them and they the clip of us
talking like we talked directly to
camera but like hi t news welcome we
hope you use this in your caption today
and that clip is certainly circulated
the e news office so we are making moves
from our little studio in New York oh my
god it's really impressive how far the
Internet can take you I mean you know
like hello it's wild
it is Ellen DeGeneres I swear stole that
stupid and then made a game out of it
the retract her in your mouth okay you
would did that my dentists and I came up
with that like three years ago in her
chair and she would and we called it to
talk but that's a better name no she
ain't right by the way there's like oh
there's probably like two thousand girls
and their dentists like around the world
who think that Ellen DeGeneres stole her
name so I don't think Ellen made that
game up I think she like bought the
concepts money made like that game what
do you mean people are like [ __ ] Jerry
invented it like no he didn't it was
like a very small business that he
bought for like a couple thousand
dollars you know and now meet it like
he's not that creative like it was
another game and he bought it and then
made it big because of his Instagram is
it is it related to words
what's one no it's stolen it's like this
what what criminal Oh cards and humanity
you know it's like a stolen concept but
like for younger people Jackie actually
was on vacation with Zach's family and
they bought it like for the trip because
there was a bunch of kids and it was
like the most inappropriate game ever
it's stupid actually my guy yeah you
have it
yeah cards get is a cartoon I'll talk
about what do you mean yeah cards
against no it was a gift
oh but from a not good friend from my
lease don't buy a I know don't buy it
like buy it's not worth it don't buy it
you know and I just can't support him in
his fake company please just do not I
can't say no I I love to shout to him he
shall take me like art is it a war it's
full fledge like I would love to run
into him I'm gonna break his nose oh my
god what would you do we just break his
nose no no you can't go to jail for that
no he okay so like him and Ben used to
be friendly they use play bass ball
together in the movie yeah so like it's
like a really awkward and close we come
from like the same like Jewish community
yeah and honestly like there was we were
never like friendly but we never like
publicly shamed one another because
like we come from it's like a small
community right and then all my stuff
happen like he took it as an opportunity
to bless me like yeah which is just like
fine whatever like I can't say I can't
say I wouldn't have done the same so now
I'm now now I don't feel the need to
protect like when I see him in public
I'm going to break his nose I'm gonna
use what they taught me in Miss
Congeniality and use my like this part
of your hand and you go up from and I'm
short and he's tall from below and break
his nose
I can't wait there's one person if I
ever run in say yes say yes say that you
without her being able to sue and/or
arrest me because I was filming her okay
so I will hock the biggest like combo is
it who is it I can't say I'll tell you
after is it Laurie Brigham ah no it's
[Music]
Taylor okay I'm sorry I have to say the
story I have to I have to my god I'm
gonna die obviously you know I don't
even want to say it cuz like nobody
knows who this woman is like now I'm
making her like a spectacle but I'm
sorry I've said I love I'm sorry
hi I'm stuck between and I know you I'm
I said no reflection on Taylor
sort of so when Taylor's were Taylor
left serious you were exploring she's
gonna watch that's good she should
because actually no she was being mean
to me for being a millennial so why
would she watch it a millennial Morning
Show ready here's what the here's what
it is I just had to say I'm sorry - yeah
no I'm fine I don't care ready
I never said this because like nobody
knows who she is she's like literally
like this lowly guest radio it's like
she's a nobody sorry bad
so when Taylor's show got cancelled on
Sirius you were exploring a bunch of
different opportunities yes to do your
show maybe a where maybe there's a
podcast a week you were recording a demo
for Spotify yeah and it was like a fake
episode they just wanted like see what
you could do right yeah and so you had
this girl glory who is like um I don't
know she's someone who she's like home
and garden right she is good
housekeeping Oh simcha so she she's in
the magazines for like a long time she's
like magazine people you ever yeah so
she was your co-host like for this fake
demo and then I was the guest yes and I
guess you must have been in the studio
recording for a while like you had this
before I got there an hour like there
was 30 minutes like you guys are in your
rhythm and then I came on as a guest and
we were just like talking about morning
breath we were just you and I like we
could talk moving into Prevert like we
could talk about anything yeah and like
the dynamic very obviously shifted one
second
the room cuz like we were like best
friends like talking like saying like in
totally a million times right where she
was just like you know the more
established mature woman in the she
definitely average mature yes and I was
just like being myself which I know can
be very like annoying and off-putting to
people who don't get ya mean you are a
'special yes but I really connect with
people my own age is what I'm trying to
say here very much Milani yes and I'm
very proud like I mean I'm an elder
millennial you know I I'm a cusper oh
yes but she is not a malign you know she
is not and she was like not feeling me
whatsoever and she was like coming for
me and like these little digs like and I
was like wait is this woman being mean
to me and I'm like I couldn't tell if I
was just being sensitive or like someone
was digging at me and then she said
something just like well yeah you know
you and your generation you're just like
needy and immature I was like oh she's
totally coming for me and then I was
like okay [ __ ] I'll come for you too
they're like thanks guys and I was like
[ __ ] my god
it's like she wasn't even a part of the
conversation like you and I were just
going back and forth about like Stassi
like just Vanderpump rules like things I
mean or south of it things that we
normally talked about and like homegirl
was just like obviously being left out
and she was like non-stop like just
coming for able to say this you guys
didn't vibe no not at all but like I
just want to say I could vibe with
anyone like it was not me
we didn't buy but because I came in
there like not liking her I'm lovely -
everyone was so nice to Clay Aiken I'm
Switzerland I was so nice to the nutty
gossip like all your all your Como's I'm
so nice - I'm a nice person I'm
Switzerland I'm Switzerland I'm
Switzerland I love you I'm Switzerland
Laurie I love you I'm Switzerland I just
like I had to say that story because
like she was so mean it was about you
know where people just don't jive and
that was one of those you know you still
work with her so I know you're not gonna
say anything and I you're good I really
do love her I believe that you guys are
very different yeah I'm sorry I get it
but you know when you're you know what
him try to introduce friends and then
like the worst thing that happens they
don't get along I mean and what if you
know any new this lady before in what
world did you think we would get along
honestly if you wanted someone to keep
your guests to get along with her you
footage should have had like [ __ ]
Martha Stewart come and be your guest
that's your life okay I don't know how
we got there but welcome to the morning
total Abbi we went there that's so great
here are the fast guys stories that you
need to know before you wake up in
take a bite out of your morning toast
you can't hear there's a little sound of
fact that we added and it's like my
favorite part of the show it's like a
munch cuz like you're taking a bite out
of the morning - oh and like that okay
so I was at the VMAs last night and
we'll talk about it a little bit on
Thursday the points guy who I went to
the VMAs with we're gonna really go in
depth but overall honestly like it was
just crazy to be there you've been ok so
I went like maybe two years ago you went
when he was at Barclays Center right no
no I actually went when it was at
Madison Square Garden
oh cool my lot of Radio City was so well
done so much better that's a vintage it
was vintage and to get in and out like
and the cab was not nearly as like
treacherous as I thought it was gonna be
like I was like that can be like you
don't have to walk 10 miles before you
can even see a car yes so it was I kind
of liked that it was small but like I
feel like it's usually like this big
huge production and it just wasn't that
do you know any mean I do so I didn't
watch it full disclosure because I was
about at 9:00 cuz I'm a loser but I was
having so much so in much FOMO it was
beyond um but yeah I got to go and when
I went I had a mental breakdown in the
limo I was yelling at my girlfriend and
my manager and well I was yelling my
manager and then my girlfriend Ellen me
to stop yelling at him and then it was
like yelling I got hurt I can yell at
him if I want to miss our relationship
right this is how I get ready for a big
event right what were you nervous about
I was not at them because they made me
wear a [ __ ] dress and I was like oh I
was saggy titted flatten it my mom and
dad didn't help matters as soon as my
mom and dad freaked me out right before
I left and they were like the red dress
makes you look thinner well I remember I
remember following you on Instagram and
I done your show once and I was like oh
my god that chuckles she one of these
and you were having people vote on the
red or the white mistake by the way I
was told by my boss the time like have
the audience vote get them involved
meanwhile I knew exactly what I was
wearing right and then everyone voted
red no you can't give people that what I
didn't people like took personal offense
the fact that I did not wear the dress
they picked so then of course the people
didn't like it were like you look gross
why do you wear the red one and my mom
dad called me and is what they do when I
get reals got to go Taylor it's mommy
and daddy okay there yeah speakerphone
tag-teaming yeah and they were like
don't wear the white one quite frankly
the red one makes you look slimmer and
you were already in the limo
you're literally my
I'm in I'm in Whiterun yeah and there's
not an option we vote red and I was like
well I vote by so then I was like my
boobs and I should take them up like the
Kardashians it was just like a whole
thing but do you have big boobs they're
big now I'm liking I'm a double D Wow
[ __ ] I'm an F don't even I'm sorry I'm
not I'm an H I'm seriously a woman I
know I always do that too yeah no I'm an
H girl yes get it yeah I know and I have
to go to special lady downtown to make
me bras but you wouldn't think because
I'm like so like petite otherwise in
terms of like my height and like my
sizing yeah and I like wearing minimizer
bras and I never wear super tight but
you wouldn't know that they're literally
bazoombas under here but yeah that's
what we call them in our family they
were like maybe C's when I wore that
dress oh that's quite a bra I didn't and
you can tell because they're saggy
central oh my god we need to find a
picture every person on the it's all my
absolute yes yes okay so the VMAs for
last night's so much happened as someone
who was there I can tell you that it's
really made for TV you know Oh totally
but like mmm there are different levels
to that right so we went to the Super
Bowl
unlike the Super Bowl halftime show like
I didn't even see I mean amazing seats I
even see Justin Timberlake and I didn't
hear him
it wasn't playing for the audience that
was like hardcore made-for-tv like we
might as well not even have been there
do you know any in for real so this was
like sealless show which I appreciate it
because having been to an event that was
like so like made-for-tv but it was
still like there was no screen like if
you're at a concert you're sitting kind
of far back and there's like a screen
and you could see the the performers up
close there wasn't any of that but it
was very cool we were on the floor the
points guy got his tickets and honestly
I don't know how he's so cool like he
got us amazing seats on the floor like
behind all the real celebrities insane
yeah it was crazy and like just to have
been there and like see people walking
by it was like so epic um we were
sitting next to this door that was like
the tunnel for like famous people to
come in and out of backstage so like I
guess when they didn't want our like
seat some performers or during the
commercials they would go chill
backstage and then when it was their
time to like be President it would come
back to their seats so it was really
cool we basically saw everyone except I
didn't see Kylie and I was like really
annoyed about it like okay she was
literally the most famous person there
it's so crazy how famous she is yeah I
know we talked about in Chuck Taylors oh
yeah you know that will air as a taste
of Taylor like in a couple weeks okay
but I can't with her
I'm sorry I know you schooled me and I
get it a little bit more and I
appreciate the perspective but like
she's at least deserving to the most
name is Kardashian I'm sorry I mean it
Kim took it right she deserves it I
can't even go into this again because
I'm tired I know but there was a lot of
people from the hills there and I was
like oh that's so cute and then it made
sense because I got a notification on my
news app that MTV announces the hills
reboot by the 2018 VMAs and they were
like um like hinting at this big reveal
and honestly I did not think it was
gonna be this and good on MTV for being
so [ __ ] in tune with what's necessary
ha the comeback of I Spencer and Heidi
really I think is the impetus behind
this because the people that they got
didn't get Lauren and they get Whitney
didn't get like the real a Christian
like they didn't get them they got like
some of the side pieces chef Justin
Bobby who was there last night now
honestly he's so handsome like nah yeah
and he's a dad I think and he's in
recovery and he's like having a really
good life and I hope this show doesn't
Leary [ __ ] it up for him you know
because you know all the terrible things
that happened to him it's like what is a
product of the show yeah so now that
he's got his life together I really hope
that the hell is not gonna like take it
back um in an Audrina yes she was there
too and she some the most dead behind
the eyes his homegirl is are you kidding
me with your coughs stop it everyone in
this room is disgusting we have podcast
listeners please okay what were you
saying to me Oh Audrina yeah see like
she's look better I know that's really
me to say but just like in person I was
just like oh yeah remember when you were
like the most beautiful woman in the
entire world in the world in the way
scoffs yeah just being beautiful as
beautiful she's she's equally as boring
yeah and that template's emulated but it
was really cool to just like be around
them and Spencer had he brought their
kid and I just old is that baby he
honestly is big like I don't think they
had the baby more than a year ago but
the baby was like poppin like huge G
yeah it wasn't even wearing the
headphones anymore that like it should
be wearing at a concert right but that's
bad parenting no but they brought the
kid to the Taylor Swift concert and he
was wearing that buttons huh and you're
supposed to but the kid is like huge now
like I was like I felt old like I was
watching him grow up do you know what I
mean yes yes yeah he's grow so fast it
always blows my mind so scared it's
really scary but so they've locked down
I think five or six like sealless cast
members but they also Spencer and Heidi
like
spearheading which is huge I wonder why
Kristin Cavallari didn't hop on board
because homegirls thirsty as hell so I
think it's a contractual issue ke and E
is what is NBC unit yeah Universal and
Viacom and by but what this people
article states which is actually super
interesting is that they spoke to
Kristin Cavallari a while back about a
hills reboot and what she said was I was
about to sign a deal to do a Hills
reunion with E then heidi-and-spencer
signed that deal with MTV so there's
such a vital part of the show that we
didn't want to do it without them
so I guess that she was ready in an econ
trash he's already succinate yeah so she
was saying she would have done it if she
was free if she was going to do it cuz I
think they were trying to do it on E but
and it has to be on MTV like it couldn't
have ever been on an like another
network they let's survive that without
that like trifecta like no Brody right
and I mean Lauren is also so boring you
remember the last episode but it may be
the most mad right so like now that we
know it was all a facade like people
that aren't even friends I don't believe
it I think the end was a save facer for
the like the world laughs yeah because
they want it to be like we're distance
we're reading scripts and all right if
Lauren Conrad can act that boring she
deserves an Oscar no but she's like the
most amazing like like of all time great
so bori know who was discovered in high
school let she's playing herself
honestly that was such an epic time for
reality television
remember Laguna Beach remember Newport
Beach yes then the hills the city like a
city Whitney Port
Oh what do you feel about her I think
she's smooth fast she acts all like so
boring they all like took this Fame and
like had babies and like do home decor
like she should live in my old building
when I was married oh when you were rich
yeah when I was rich I when he pours my
neighbor and she was boring you know she
doesn't seem like the most fun-loving
gal ever but she seems like a nice
person but Kelly Cutrone is a [ __ ] and
she was a part of the city oh my god so
funny literally last night love her at
the VMAs all the people from the hills
went round and me and points guy we were
like walking to get a drink and we think
Kelly Cutrone is walking in front of us
and we are freaking out mind you like a
couple months ago I went in a whole
tirade about Kelly Cutrone because she
did this Instagram live that was just
like so abominable really I'm so
privileged it was like the most out of
control thing ever like basically shoot
her
in her neighborhood she saw someone like
like a homeless person expose themselves
yeah yeah but like a regular occurrence
in New York yeah and she called the
police and they were taking a super long
time to come and she literally like to
do this three-minute video like blasting
them like being like I live in Soho like
so like you deserve the police faster
it's like they're not coming they're
busy and it's like she saw it and left
and it's like it's not an emergency so
like they are gonna take like it was
just like such a like an out-of-control
she was just trying like blast the
police for like being busy and we went
in on her and I couldn't believe that I
never heard from her from that cuz like
sometimes the show really does have legs
and like if you say something I'm here
like you'll get repercussions right
you're lucky enough to be behind a
paywall if you say something bad like
only a certain amount of people I only
get in trouble when I put it on tasted
Taylor right yeah so I was prepared for
like a nasty DM I get DM some people's
like publicists and managers all the
time they're like really whatever so
yeah I never heard from her and then she
wasn't behind us and we were like dying
but it wasn't her she's a really good
friend of mine oh she is so I am again
oh my god I'm out here like slaying all
your friends I'm sorry no honest I don't
know anything about her but all I know
was that video I'm like a winged kind of
Ireland I was like this is like [ __ ]
up well I I was almost the expose
himself to myself to my girl me too and
so and I also called my mom of course
and but I didn't you know do a rant on
it no I didn't stick around I just
called 911 I was like hey I'm gonna be
sure they never came which is I'm sure
I'm sure that they did actually you
think yeah
man he was he was just wagging that
Willy all over the place where was it it
was right around the corner from my
apartment
and like right by Wall Street okay mine
was on in the Meatpacking District oh my
god at night and it was this guy he was
literally like sitting on a chair but
like this it was like a throne Jackie
calls it a throne of trash cuz like it
wasn't a chair but he was somehow like
elevated in the air sitting on like a
pile of garbage bags and he just had his
penis out I'm was stroking it and
honestly it was me Jackie and our friend
Christian and honestly like it was the
biggest penis I ever saw like it was not
human like it was the craziest thing
ever and might have just been because I
was like so unexpected not expecting to
see a penis but like it was the size
dead-ass it was it like dirt Dirk
Diggler what's that oh my god from mom
oh my god Boogie Nights
amok amok he plays a porn star and at
the end they get his porn star and it's
like they had to put a prosthetic I know
it looks prosthetic exactly ginormous
fake it was so big and honestly I look I
was so taken aback by it and I called
the police and I'm there can you give it
to him I'm like no and I'm not staying
here but just know there's like and I'm
sure I'm sure there's more calls he's
the king
yeah I was ding dong we were freaking
out and it was so dark outside I mean
we're just like we could still see it
that's how big it was ah God
where were you exposed to oh boy I'm
sitting outside
it's crazy a sky broad daylight oh
that's just down the street with his
dick
see that's but like that's New York like
she was just like she's actually I
didn't clean why is that
right so exciting away from stinky dick
we are paying exorbitant amounts of rent
just to be exposed to to be like
harassed on a regular basis our second
story is ABMA another segue with the
completely some complete list of winners
and normally on our really care because
like they're all fake awards it's just
like rich people congratulating other
rich people for like virtually doing
nothing yeah it's like don't they get
enough attention right and it's like
taking credit for work they really had
nothing to do it like they don't write
the songs they don't direct the music
videos but I thought this was really
interesting because we here at the
morning toast read a lot of just like
celeb gossip like underground
underground stuff and the VMAs are
notoriously known for just being
completely rigged I don't know yes and
they have like every year it's just like
who they aligned with so like this year
it was Ariana's here I didn't say I so I
follow her I don't follow a ton of like
celebrities on Instagram huh but I
follow her and you and and a pay later
viene yeah it was like up in her
Instagram shake and I've got what is
going on huh so and it's her and Nicki
Minaj are like this alliance they're
best friends so every time there was an
award I was literally guessing who was
gonna mean it was Ariana and Nicki every
time he's not like Nicki kept beating
cardi B which I just think is so insane
and I'm not saying this is a blanket
statement this is of the year so in this
year in particular
Nicki Minaj was virtually missing a lot
of people say she was in rehab but she
was completely gone yes she was she had
a couple songs
come out in the past like two three
months and cardi B every week it was a
new banger and not to mention like Bo
doc yellow being the absolute song of
the year but like her song with JLo her
song with girls like you was the best
song ever like you cannot deny that this
was the year of cardi B and yes she one
new artist of the year because Nicki
Minaj was not in that category obviously
she was gonna beat Hayley kiyoko like
MTV's working so hard to make Hayley
kiyoko famous I have no idea who she is
like I don't know and who who was her
manager
I want Hayley kiyoko as manager because
that [ __ ] gets everywhere it's got to
be scattered abroad totally and nobody
knows who she is and she's one song that
sounds vaguely familiar to me someone
who was like so in it like I listen to
everything and I've never heard of Kelly
Kyoko whatever people don't give me [ __ ]
for that cuz I can parently she's like
she's a cult following but I've never
met anyone I don't know Paul but isn't
she on the Big Bang Theory what's her
name I don't know it's Kaley Cuoco oh
yeah something like that that's so true
names such similar Daisy Coco Cantley
cuoco well she got married now so she's
Kelly cook Oh which is a really cute
name actually and she gets to keep her
initials but so according be one nervous
of the year because she had really no
competition yes but any time she was up
against sticky not Nicki Minaj should
win and I think that's just so
unrealistic and cuz that's someone look
I'm an ideal viewer I'm someone who
would vote in the VMAs yeah I listen to
all genres of music and I really don't
have alliances I just like good music
and that's what it should be about or it
should be about the numbers and cardi
B's at the top of every chart like I
just thought it was so unrealistic and
even Ariana and I'm on her number one
stand her winning in some of the
categories made a lot of sense
but in other categories it did not make
a lot of sense and especially this thing
about it like no girl just came out yeah
same with um Queen which is Nicki Minaj
new album so like in terms of the year
I'm saying like it was just so
unrealistic and then to top it all off
Camila Cabello
winning video of the year I've never
even seen the video said hunan yeah yeah
and then when she was up against me yeah
okay she was up against Drake who like I
don't even listen to Drake and I've
watched about splendid music video 1,000
times cuz it was the most epic beautiful
moving thing of my life yeah he took the
$900,000 that he was given by the studio
and just hands it out to people on the
street at Miami who needed it and filmed
it like literally on a phone it was like
so epic and that song is amazing like I
can't believe that Camila Cabello beat
Drake and
I said her name I was like what [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and then so
much weight then so you're just like
raging anger and like at some point I
wasn't even listening cuz I'm like I
know who they're gonna do I'm like it's
so fake you could literally guess it and
the only interesting really thing that
happened that was obviously unplanned
cuz the whole thing is very scripted is
Kevin Hart and Tiffany Haddish came out
and did like a little monologue
they weren't the hosts it was more so
just like I don't know them like being
funny commenting on all the things and
they made like a funny fifth harmony
joke about how Camila is like the other
four like dying because I Camillus like
out here winning awards right and then
when Nicki Minaj came to accept one of
her awards that she won undeserving Lee
um she made a comment she's like don't
come for my girl normanni and I was like
what it was still awkward I wish they
pan to commit like a bailout but
apparently normanni is like the next
beyoncé and I haven't heard a single
thing she's done huh yeah he's like
Camila behind the scenes right like it
was totally ruining her life
but like normani has just like people
like she's the next beyoncé that's what
people saying people don't say that on
I'm like that's a be like she is I've
never even seen her dance like I this is
what I'm saying like these award shows
are just getting so out of control in
the sense that like people are being
rewarded for doing nothing like normanni
is out here like the talk of the town
she doesn't have song out and she wasn't
even there yeah just cuz Nicki Minaj
gave a shot right no it's just like it's
too much for me and all these lists so
can we look upon oh they want Havana for
video of the year artist of the year was
Camila Cabello artist of the year up
against Bruno Mars Tom Hardy be Drake
post Malone in Ariana Grande really
Flula Camela was headless not even a
headliner she's on tour opening for
someone like still very prestigious for
Telescope but like that's crazy
who is Camila Cabello painting was
Taylor so it's part of any of this no so
that's what the underground blog says it
says every year they really align
themselves with someone some days some
years it couldn't Kidman Kanye and it
couldn't have been Ariana and Taylor it
had to be one or the other because I'm
just like two divas we're gonna had a
brutal year yes so I and I saw an
interview she did where she like broke
down it was yep Oh sincere and I love
our out of that mature even more and
since then I was like you know what cuz
I was kind of like s we nervous and then
I went back and realest and having that
knowledge I was like okay I love this
and also that song that you put on
Instagram story which one when your
promo
we coming on like on Sunday was like my
night oh yeah yeah that's such a good
song and also I felt mad about the album
too but then after the was it bed oh I
don't know mark what's a called take
back everything the light is coming oh
yeah it's so good but after the VMAs she
had a like a private concert at Irving
Plaza that points got obviously got me a
ticket to to and like we were like
living and she's such an amazing
performer and actually I changed my mind
the songs are amazing no no they're
amazing she's amazing she's like she's
mini better Mariah Carey
yeah no much better she's like a toddler
but like in Mariah's heyday she was that
big now like Mariah like forgot how to
sing but I think that like Ariana will
never go that diva diva route so I was
like a very 90s thing was to be that big
of a deal also she's been through like a
huge tragedy and she's like really like
the type of celebrity who like loves her
fans like you know that there are pop
stars out there who literally hate their
fans literally like Selena Gomez in
definitely bother like they don't want
to talk to their fans they hate their
fans it's so crazy real yes their fans
are [ __ ] love them and like they want
to be nowhere near them like they hate
me great so you know what I mean really
yes I mean I know Justin Bieber
definitely yes but Auriemma grande loves
her fans she definitely does mhmmm just
interesting all the time yeah but I'd
like it I just hated it and now I love
it yes I feel like I know a lot you know
I believe it do you believe it yeah well
yes yes yes I think I don't think it's
goodto getting engaged me too and I
don't think it's fake no I do think he's
like a commitment junkie like he always
loves long-term relationship I just
honestly like a like a hot quality I
hate the opposite like guys who don't
want to be tied down yeah sure Pete
Davidson is like tie me down let's have
kids like get hot yes I just think I do
I'm not down there no Nick and Priyanka
are like they are really in love I just
think it's fueled a lot by like bad
things do you know any me and like I
think that together they party a lot do
you I do okay he was clean and sober is
he's hobart well he would him in his
friend were pulled over yesterday
morning and the friend was arrested for
possession of drugs which means like
they both had drugs we'd be like yeah
yeah I'm getting all the drug go to jail
I'll give you $50,000 yeah that's like
something to do one of these days like
someone's gonna like give me drugs
because like I liked like a celebrity
like I want to hang out all the
celebrities and I want to be their
friends like oh yeah I'll go to prison
for you and I'll just take all the drugs
like when we all get pulled over one day
you know
oh yes oh I've you all yeah whatever in
any hole but and then I feel like they
need but they definitely pay you for
that you know they'll pay your bail to
pick you up out a person likes em until
I feel like you get like a little
Christmas bonus yeah yeah job all done
yeah
good job drug mills bad job hiding it
yeah yeah no honestly that's what I just
feel I feel like their relationship is
sincere in the sense that they're [ __ ]
obsessed with each other but oh I think
they're not great influences on one
another interesting interesting now I'm
now I really want to go well cuz I do
think he's a party boy and she's not but
she brings this whole new level of Fame
to his life yeah and right and he's like
at parties now that like he would never
have been invited to before so he's at a
level now that like you can't do
anything but drugs do you know what I
mean yeah yeah I just like constantly
around he has a super addictive
personality exactly so it's like maybe
some of you go in there who doesn't have
that but him that's a lot of temptation
exactly okay third story Ben Affleck and
Lindsay shook his breakup after one year
of dating oh my god
it's officially over for Ben Affleck and
Lindsay shook it's the 46 year old actor
in the 38 year old SNL producer I've
called it quits after a year of dating
enews can confirm Affleck and shook us
like I can't even say that name with
like shook us I am shook us by the story
active legend Jacques took two split two
to three weeks ago E News has learned
they are still very amicable and have
stayed friends a source said they both
tried to make it work but the distance
just proved to be too much for them
right now
family comes first for both of them yeah
I had a lot of Clem faced with
conflicting feelings about this because
when a a man in a relationship like a
long marriage exits a marriage usually
goes like a ten-year-old model so I kind
of love that he was taking like a
30-year old writer like 38 year-old
nut she wasn't like a you know 25
year-old model she's like an established
writer she writes for SNL the Walmart
yeah but anyone who is in Ben Affleck's
life that's not Jennifer Garner I hate
so I hate her well he was also spotted
with a Playboy model right that's
literally like the break-up right the
cause of the break-up but and it's so
interesting that now he news is saying
that they broke up three weeks ago if so
that now he was spotted at a drive-thru
with a Playboy model and like you're
supposed to think well oh he broke up
three weeks ago so then after I'm from
Boston so I automatically have to like
love him
uh-huh but like he and his brother oh
[ __ ] back no the brother I'm
not here for no and that's like the
drums wayward he's out of control that's
like the depravity of Hollywood like
that he won an Oscar and I got a
standing ovation didn't even address the
fact that so many people said he like
molested them on set like so disgusting
and like Hollywood pretends to be like
times that meet you great
he's kids yeah black times up let's go
go to prison please they also give him
standing ovations Mel Gibson like please
I can't I can't
but so Ben is like he's just like a bad
dirty boy he's got a sewer dick yes he's
like what a sewer dick so we're dick is
just like a dirty dirty and darling
that's a good sewer dick right yeah I
like that oh yeah at college I have I
did the guy that my friends calls
through dick thanks no rag yeah those
green days are over
I'm good but I just think he's like he's
just all stereotypes that a bad
stereotype a guy would be yeah cheater
a gambler yeah heavy drinker yeah he's
just like he's just like a walking
problem yeah and I hate it I'm like mmm
everybody got so much backlash for being
cast as Batman oh my god that was funny
and like kind of sad I loved him in the
town I mean he is amazing movies could
bowhunting it's like the best movie ever
oh and he's such a good actor what else
is he in he was in one like the
accountant that was super weird and you
know he only does like smart movies so
that I don't like to watch you know he's
really good but he I mean I just like my
Boston boy I wish she was like act more
like math right no Matt is such a good
guy right I think I don't feel he cheats
ever on his like nobody wife right now
by the way you can always tell that
celebrities are good guys when they have
nobody wives get Mark Wahlberg so true
so rich like I'm sure you get anyone he
wants anyone want a boy that he is the
face of Boston he is he I think he's
nervous he is the Wahlberg's in general
well I'm such a big Donnie Wahlberg that
really for so many reasons one him and
his wife met i watch happens live which
is just I know that you feel a certain
type of way about her because she had a
competing show it's serious and she
wasn't very nice to you if we didn't
that was the thing that was the issue it
wasn't a competition like but like all
of a sudden when our shows was so we
used to be oh we were eight to you or
seven to ten seven to ten you're right
you forgot I forgot we were seven said
but oh for a while we were 69
of torture and so there was an hour
between our show and Jenny show and it
was all good she was super nice to me
the second we got pushed back against
her show she got like really like
sunglasses on like wouldn't say hi and
I'm like are you mad cuz I'm in your
space gray and we ended the show early
just to accommodate them which was worse
we did not have to do and it was like
50/50 it was like sometimes she won ice
I play with her puppies right yeah she
was like attitude central and I just
like didn't know where the [ __ ] was
coming from well she definitely seems
like she has diva-like qualities
especially now that she you left and
she's like the reigning queen a woman
dr. Laura Schlessinger is still the
quaint of that Channel okay but this is
the reasons why I like Donnie Wahlberg
yes I love that they men i watch happens
live like regardless how you feel like
that's an epic way to meet like just you
we're both guests loved it
yeah and they're married I am [ __ ]
head over heels in love with Blue Bloods
it's the best show of all time
my mom is obsessed it's the greatest you
have to watch it and you have to watch
do you watch like SVU um okay so it's
it's a more elevated SVU in the sense
you really get to know the characters
more elevated might be better in terms
of character development no okay
storylines in the same order figure it
out that's why I love it for you it's
like I could go like seasons pop it at
11:00 to be like I mean for the most yes
yes
it's the same vibe you can pop into any
bluebloods and as long as you know the
dynamic like that they're all family you
pretty much can follow along okay but
it's really nice to like have this crime
show but then also have a secondary
storyline of like people getting married
people falling in love people breaking
up a death like all that stuff and it's
in Boston no it's in New York
oh so it's all about the NYPD and
they're like this family of like one of
them is a district attorney one of them
is a detective one of them is a cop on
the street one of them is a police
commissioner majority or no they're so
moral and you can really learn a lot
about just like values they're always
talking about like they've they've
dinner every night on Sunday together
that's like their thing they're like the
Reagan family dinner and there they have
kids at the dinner they have the grand
pop the dinner at the great grandma and
at all just like they're talking about
like moral dilemmas they're always just
like talking about values do you know
any mean yes it's really interesting and
like I'm always like a valuating like
what would I do
and the police commissioner was played
by Tom Selleck he is a shot disease
massage yes thank God otherwise and the
show please yes everyone the show is
eight years old so you can see him eight
years ago when he's like really hot now
he's like a little old but
he see I know and there's 22 episodes
every season it's CBS like no joke is he
making Bank yeah
the highest-paid one is Tom Selleck and
I believe Donnie Wahlberg company he's
an executive producer who is Donnie oh
[ __ ] he's making a lot is yaha
so yes that's why I love him okay and
he's a part of this great family I feel
like they have really good values like I
watch the Wahlburgers is the show
probably the wire no rumor that no they
don't get off who da remark well in the
rumor it's a rumor I'm is that makes a
leash ed and it might have to do
something with Jenny its rumors okay
just speak yeah I I'm gonna remember
that
it's not like they're not crazy about
Jenny oh the bear is not or and or their
relationship gotta yeah well I could see
that cuz they're like very down-to-earth
but they never moved out of Austin like
like I said Mark exactly has a no-name
wife like legend I wouldn't be very good
I could see why they wouldn't like her
honestly like she yeah and also like I
feel like turned on e or super obsessed
each other which is actually very cute
me too and I did like to he would come
on and do the show and I thought that
was like yeah did they're like obsessed
with each other and I get that and they
help each other out
so like I never want to leave her side
um yeah but there every second of my
life so I liked that but I guess in a
family that's annoying especially like
if they were like reliant on Donnie
yeah if Donnie was always like the
brother that they could depend on to be
like at every family of affair right
well now I'm just concerned with like
the dynamics cuz like Mark is richer JA
and Mark is more famous and also the
baby or younger yes that's a hard pill
to swallow
yes like my sister just bought a house
I'm sure I mean I'm like what the [ __ ]
where Oh Salem Massachusetts is such a
nice life I know Jackie's always saying
we need to move to Cleveland like just
like to get the [ __ ] out of yeah like
honestly I want to live in a house and
Salem Massachusetts right I could get a
good mortgage upper house uh-uh home I
was like tell me how much yeah and I was
like I'm gonna hang me you could google
it
oh my gosh but we lied to you about how
much you paid no she didn't and it's
like amazing anyway but it's really
weird when a younger sibling yes like
kind of
achieve life status over you i'ma show
I'm positive that's how my older sister
scale about me honestly no wait what is
the birth order in your family Olivia
Jackie me Margot no people get think I'm
too in Jackie's three because I'm like
bigger physically like they just assume
I'm older maybe it's like some wisdom
behind my eyes but Jackie's old woman
she's 20 you guys like to to to to to
it's so yeah Olivia's 26 Jackie's 25 I'm
24 my goes to 21 oh my god Frank close
wait well you guys like force to be
friends when you're growing up um yes
and then it actually stuck you know
stuck it did backfire it didn't backfire
that's lucky yeah I mean be hung out
with each other cuz like we there was
like always people around like there was
always someone to hang out with because
you had one of three sisters right and
there's always different alliances you
know right growing up is really like me
and Margot Versace and Olivia cuz they
were like cool and in middle school had
cell phones they would like lock the
room and like not let us say nobody we'd
be like a banging on the door and then
we're like [ __ ] you [ __ ] and me would
like play like like like on the computer
and like a foosball like we would just
we had our leg wrestle and chip and then
dynamic shifted because we grew up a
little bit and then mean Olivia really
like bonded over our love for SVU oh my
gosh I mean he would spend weekends just
laying in bed watching SVU just osteo
Margo had that make you feel but then
her and Jackie yeah her and Jackie like
we're obsessed with each other and then
it was like we got annoyed at them for
being so obsessed with each other and
now dynamics have shifted once again
because me and Jackie spend so much time
together yeah I mean really do have like
overlapping interests yes and Margo has
like a reals but but bursting social
life outside of our sisters we're like
none of us do like we the sisters have
like one or two or three like really
good friends yes but we don't have like
a million girlfriends to go out to
dinner with and Margo is like a [ __ ]
full social events calendar yes she
spends a lot of time away from us now
like being with her friends which I
guess is fine so me and Jackie spend a
lot of time together and Olivia's in it
like a new relationship
yeah so they're like all in all the time
so many it's really like me and Jackie
and everyone else has a life but me and
Jack are like old married ladies now
that like we just hang out together and
we live two blocks from each other no
[ __ ] yeah I love I mean like we have a
lot of TV to watch together to recap on
the show so you guys watch it together
it is yeah but economics are always
constant shifting but there's never been
like a bad dynamic which is good like
we're like someone hates each other I
know I love that I love like I mean I'm
from a family of three and we're so far
apart you girls one boy yep I'm on the
oldest and Paige you
yes girl don't act like it I have taken
only you do what seven years but like a
be an older like the oldest siblings
like a responsibility J deal that
massive responsibility and like my
sister and I I adore her but like I'm
I'm very aware that like I am her big
sister the Sheep warships looks up to
cuz we're I'm so much older I feel that
way tomorrow yeah fight with her even if
she annoys me because I feel like all
like break her life and I've also
learned that through watching my
girlfriend Taylor her film dynamics cuz
like and not that her sister Ashley is
the [ __ ] best
but like tape warships her old there's
the same age difference between me and
Paige so so I feel like now I'm seeing
it two different eyes so I'm like oh my
god I love how we've taken this Ben
Affleck breakups right to this just I
think it's important for you to know
where we started I'll keep going no key
but Ben Affleck is not a good family
right terrible sibling what we were
sitting how we got to here is
celebrities with no name uh wives yes
like not that she's no name but Matthew
McConaughey's wife she's beautiful and
she's not no name but she's like what is
she any because of him right writer
named Camila right she's gorgeous
yes yes um and their kids are like so
hot and they're gonna be so hot who else
is a good guy Oh Oh Pierce Brosnan Margo
made a huge happened to Andrew Jackman
totally and Pharrell who's he married to
right right
she was that a baby they look we said uh
we set in front of them actually there's
a girl and they were a behind us and
they like put them in more sweet nice
and Kevin Hart no he does have a no-name
my for me know her name now cuz it's
your daughter yeah exactly
okay fourth story and wanted to
introduce some businesses because I
think it's important for everyone to be
super well-rounded its eleven eleven
Make A Wish ever unpause it make a wish
thank you is that we were gender wish it
with and I hope people are jealous with
me I was gonna end my wish like this but
I'm not doing I mean I'm just I can't do
that honestly if I was what are you
Catholic or Christian Catholic is there
difference I mean it's just like
Catholics are like more like intense
Christians like you have to feel like
way more we're actually like the Jews
nation I get I guess like so many rules
if I was Catholic or Christian I would
[ __ ] do this all the time because I
think it's like a dramatic funny thing
to do like in my set I always wanted to
do it and I did it once you sure I just
feel weird about it like it's you feel
like you're like Neil sack with like I'm
gonna burn like it's like a sacrilege
saying I don't I don't know it's just I
know I don't know I just think a would
be so funny and they want to see people
do it in shows like it's always like a
great comic tool I like there are tons
of times where I say stuff and I need it
I'm like why don't you do with this
praise baby Jebus cuz Jesus is not real
okay so but you say it though it's the
same walk because people get crazy about
Jesus and I always like I have this joke
about like Jesus is like so hot with his
like six-pack people get mad at wavy
hear very mad people Dixon people are
very serious about religion yes yes
right yes so but no I wish I was Jewish
I am Jewish what is Taylor she's half
Jewish she is back in yeah that counts
that counts yes sir and it's through her
mother so your kids are totally some
Jewish Jews us yes again thank baby jeez
well because you live in New York
honestly like if you're not sure if you
feel left out how that's like the only
place in the world where that happens
legit look I go look I I know for a fact
that when I go to some of my shows or
like people who follow me on Instagram
that I'm like their first experience
with the Jewish person that is so crazy
it's so crazy
if you don't believe me when I say that
I remember one was one and I went on her
honeymoon and I was I was like I'm mrs.
I'm not gonna say her last name but I
was like wait wait um was Ben was Jewish
yes it's Jewish yes yes very and so um I
would say like they would identify as
conservative but I think that they're
actually a skosh more they're not like
I'm can dye second serve it as scotch
scotch what is that no wait what's
what's the like the lowest life form
reformed but I think that they're in
between reformed and conservative okay
yeah those were firm reform conservative
Modern Orthodox Orthodox like Hasidic
Harini like crazy all righty
yeah that's like next level that's like
what
try to be no that's a Kabbalah yeah yeah
no that's like not really Jewish it just
like it steals things from Judaism so I
wouldn't lead women so we're doing
really had a very Mykonos at Santorini
so highly rich oh yeah so we had a very
Jewish last name and I was like I'm mrs.
solid though we're married ah we're
Jewish yeah I was so proud and he was
like you cannot mm-hmm talk about this
in Europe and I was like why he's like
there's anti-semitism and yet I was sure
yeah no no and so but that's why I'm
always like out here preaching about
being Jewish because it's really like I
think that a lot of people who live in
certain parts the world like just have
really never met a Jewish person and
what they what they know about them is
like fables and like a stereotypes like
that like you got a hook a hook nose and
you're working a bank well the bank
thing is true but like you know like oh
they have horns
and then I make them like no no like is
that your little notes that person
somebody's grandfather who was like from
the 19 like 30 you know but it's like
when you live in certain parts of the
country you
there's no Jewish community and now
traveling all over like I'm always like
look up like if there's like a hub on
nearby or just like what the Jewish and
vibe is like and that's why I like our
organizations like kebab like their job
is like they want to be everywhere so if
you're travelling to a town and you want
to have like Shabbat somewhere like go I
went to Shabbat in Denver and it was so
epic
I had Shabbat at the Wailing Wall you
did yeah we were supposed to go to San
Tropez and then we changed the plans I
mean he was like surprised when Israel's
my mom and I was like I mean I made the
best of it
wait when you called it the Wailing Wall
I'm like what is that because that's
like the like the that's what's called
the coat no no you are I think it's fine
it's fine I remember it's like the
English version of it but what it's
called that's what it is it's a Kotel
hotel motel holiday inn western wall
western wall but it is still called the
Wailing Wall everyone dolphins there
yeah look at me
shamans if you're here I and I speak
like yet it fluently
I love yet it's just so sad that's like
a dying language so my dad and my
wedding was like we're so happy she's
marrying a mensch oh my god
it is so sweet now we're divorced okay
but we could go together we were
standing so big tuition we took this by
the way I just would miss being rich
like that's from Forbes the world's
highest-paid actresses of 2018 Scarlett
Johansson steals the spotlight with 40
million won this year yep move over Emma
Stone who was the highest-paid actress
last year Tinseltown has a new high
speed actress Scarlett Johansson leads
this year's ranking with 14.5 million in
pre-tax earnings but that's so sad cuz
then you mean it's Johnny it's why yeah
I depend on where she lives but in
California I think it's like it's half
sorry I put it in between June of 2017
in June of 2018 what movies did she do
playing Black Widow in Marvel's Avengers
Marvel makes money has become lucrative
role for Johnson who cripples for 2017
earnings oh my god to bump Emma Stone
from number one should return on screen
for the fourth installment of the
superhero conglomerate series in 2019
quote the percent of budget costs have
certainly skewed heavily particularly on
the Avengers movies to cast now whereas
maybe in the early ones it was more
visual effects or below the line so
basically what they're saying is like
now they can do everything on a computer
that they need less money on like sets
and like action like that they can they
the more out the ass that is so crazy I
mean you know what's so crazy I would
love to know I'm this article doesn't
say what the world's highest-paid actor
is I would love I bet it's like 7d I bet
just like giving like 77 cents on the
dollar like the math yeah but this
article doesn't say which is really
upsetting um but you know what's even
more interesting like homegirl is still
the highest paid actress of all time and
she just stepped out of a role she was
cast as a transgender person there's a
lot of controversy around it and so hey
she gets she she said she's not gonna do
it I feel like she's such an advocate
for just like all things progressive
that blows my mind that she would step
out of it there must be a reason that
makes sense well they were the reasoning
why and I don't really have a particular
opinion on this so I'm just given the
facts she was cast in a role as a
transgender person and while the LGBTQ
community was really excited that
finally like a transgender person was
going to be depicted in modern
television or movies they were upset
that they didn't take it as an
opportunity to cast a transgender
actress I get it because they are have
so few opportunities like they're not
given equal opportunities and
laughing I get it yeah but I also think
that because she's such a huge star and
actually gives it more legs so like the
mainstream audience right which is then
definitely forwarding the movement yeah
we all you know are fighting for I feel
both ways about it cuz it's like it's
it's so great that it happened and like
we are moving forward like this would
never have had their never would've been
a movie about a transgender person 20
years ago so like we really are moving
forward and having Scarlett Johansson
attached to it like would be epic but at
the same time like if you're gonna be
progressive it's just like go all in
yeah but maybe I shouldn't say this but
I'm gonna say it anyway because I have
no [ __ ] filter but it's like if you
want the movie to be as successful as
humanly possible you have ready to star
in especially the high-speed actor
totally she would win an Oscar you ever
get so much press and I feel like if
they don't put in a notable actress and
unfortunately right now I don't think
there are any guys gendered men Cox I
think is the most well okay you're right
yeah could she would she sell as much as
would she like bring as much no but she
would still bring a lot of attention
yeah like I'm gonna say I'm think
they're gonna go with like in a complete
like non unknown yeah and then it's
gonna like just be more of like an
independent yeah no I just I feel two
ways about it cuz I'm like I'm really
like I really feel like at a crossroads
because like at one point it's like
you're acting so you're not supposed to
be what you're pretending to be you know
it's like if you play someone who is a
nurse but in real life you're an actor
are you lying you don't I mean like like
where do we draw the line but then also
it's like while this is a big moment
like let's go all the way with the
progression like Disney Channel has cast
their first gay character in one of
their shows it's a gay boy really he's
the character is gay but it's played by
a straight man and to me it's just like
who can play a gay man better then again
man I know that to me that makes me
angry
that made me angry that just pissed me
on here like that's it that to me is a
bad business me off than the transgender
thing should be should yeah would you
watch me ride yes of course okay so when
they had I was like dying when they had
the UM transgendered once was a girl now
is I guess what transitioning or is a
man transition to amend but they are a
man out and you for as they are man out
so he but I feel like that episode was
so important because just cuz you're in
the LGBTQ and all the other new letters
I know I don't know them
I am learning as I go community doesn't
mean that you can understand the story
of every single person so the
transgender see I'm still I feel like
ignorant on I'm still learning yeah and
so but I think we're all like in the
same boat yes because like and I know
the transgender community doesn't like
her but like Caitlyn Jenner did a lot I
know it's too but the here's the thing
Bruce Jenner was boring so Kayla dinners
not gonna be dynamic you know but I'm
just saying she did get a personality
transplant her story like yeah being on
ABC Diane Sawyer like literally
broadcasting to like millions and
millions of people who a might never
have even heard of transgender fair B
might like be bigoted against if you
didn't see that like this is a real
thing because I Bruce pre yeah what's
such like an American hero no totally
and then third like maybe there's some
kids sitting in his bedroom being like
you know I kind of feel like a girl yeah
and like this like puts it into
perspective you know yes I don't know I
just I feel a lot of takeaways about it
I feel like you can't comment on I was
out getting in trouble no but from
either side and I'm right in the middle
I agree with everyone honestly I
actually um I interviewed Nick Cannon a
while back right after I started dating
Taylor and on civil divorce everything
and I was like cats Neosho I'm so
interesting and he was like no are you
transgender do you think is your
changing gender and I was like no he's
like not interested what a girl
gay is boring what's show and he was
like transgender is what's up
transgender is anything out that we
wanted to be on huh that is so funny
anything I was just begging okay I
honestly saved for jobs that's such an
agenda there's a guess here Mike what
can you do for me yeah I make sure I
welcome you to my show what can you do
for me yeah okay so Johnson scratch
Manson she edged Angelina Jolie who's
number two for 28 million but how home
girl doesn't leave the house she didn't
imagine making 28 million girls a year
without leaving her house no no that is
the dream that is the dream no but they
also they include so Jennifer Aniston
who's at number three was stealing
million because you want to know why now
this actually makes sense residual state
his friends residual but now this at all
making sense to me it's not just acting
it's our boss SmartWater
right so same as College minutes and she
was Soda Stream which yesterday got
bought for three billion dollars so you
have to calculate that as well like
Sophia Vergara is the highest-paid
actress on TV and she's also head and
shoulders you have
see ya nutribullet coffee ninja like
she's she's on every [ __ ] commercial
so it's not even the fact that she's
actually she's not the highest-paid
woman on television Judge Judy is Wow
but Sofia Vergara is right there
wrong is she yeah I want she gets to sit
all day and judge people and and make
money like I do that for free
Reese Witherspoon joins the list with
big little eyes also I feel like because
she's in her production company oh right
yeah no it's just interesting how
celebrities make money outside of like
classic salaries but what's her face who
was in the friggin flippers TV show
uh-huh HGTV Joanna and chip and Joe
yeah no and she she has that business
honor whatever it is honest honest
company Jessica Alba thank you yeah she
blows you Mike she does even work
anymore in Hollywood but her Tom Horner
nicely hot no he made out with a band
he's a sock sock company it's a no he's
Rob Kardashian skinny Rob Kardashian
yeah and lot hotter yeah no I just
and you know what else I I have learned
that when celebrities do these like big
big campaigns with with companies like
that are less you know like Sofia
Vergara and that coffee thing Coffee
ninja what was it called like whatever
so it was a relatively new product so
her putting her face on it like gave it
such legs that she now owns a percentage
of the company of course so like they
just they know how to make money in
Hollywood I gotta get there we gotta
move you know what is its managers its
agents yeah who are like professional
bloodsuckers you got it you got that's
we gotta be our final final final story
of the day is like I just can't even
it's like so stupid People magazine
Chrissy Teigen quote projectile puked at
daughters school orientation
Chrissy taken me Chrissy Teigen I can't
[ __ ] his big
made a memorable first impression at her
daughter Luna Simone school on Monday
the mother to hilariously revealed that
she and husband John Legend took their
two-year-old child to their first day
after a late night and things did not go
according with job hell this she tweeted
this hello everyone from Lunas school
orientation today I'm sorry I projectile
puked caffeine upon arrival couldn't
open my eyes and I the noisiest newborn
in the room not a joke very sorry see
you tomorrow and then she's been on the
streets again oh no it was not first day
school she's first day of school jitters
it was last night's wine and Korean
barbecue and jet-lagged combo she added
in the follow-up tweet she and
- welcome son miles Theodore on May 16th
were spotted leaving quarters Bart
Korean BBQ in Los Angeles on Saturday
it's like they just has rich people
problems like you had to throw up at
your kids orientation because you we're
like so jet-lagged from all your world
travel and then like your five-star meal
with wine last night like please I
projectile vomited from like this blood
guide to suck up off the floor cuz I
drop my shot that's like a real problem
that's why I got sick I'm getting a
little over Chrissy be like I am
relatable you're not by the way this is
the show of people who are so over Chris
ET and like people love her BuzzFeed has
created the monster like and don't get
me wrong I think she's hilarious and I
think that Hollywood did a really good
job with like picking up on her because
like before she became like the
sensation she was like a really not a
well-known model no and she like
contrary to other models out there she
is like a huge personality yes and she's
talented in other way she's like a
really good chef so I think Hollywood
did a good thing I'm like picking up on
her her talents yes um but they've taken
it way too far like every time she
tweets something it's a [ __ ] People
magazine article I had a friend who was
at a party and Chrissy was there of
course and my friend had this like white
pony like clutch that she put like on
like the arm of a chair but it was I'm
still afraid and so Chrissy came and she
was just talking to somebody not to my
friend talking to somebody and she was
sitting on the arm of the couch slashed
my friends clutched by mistake she got
up and there was an enormous red spot on
my friend's clutch and Chrissy was like
oh my god I am so sorry I period all
over your bag and she was like what is
it I'll buy you a new one which made me
love her that she would admit that if I
brought another one's bag I would steal
her bag and run away Oh what kind of bad
was it was it like oh my god my did this
reminders like wealthy so it must have
been like a [ __ ] like it was probably
like a like a Elizabeth and James right
break jillion dollar like croc oh my god
wait she period in it honestly that kind
of makes me love her like that's
actually blade well but you didn't tweet
about that you know and she should right
oh my god I guess the story but I'm like
no Queen it makes you like the coolest
but I heard something really upsetting
about John and her what I don't it's
like I
even I like every time I started story
I'm like why am i telling the story I
think it's gonna make people like very
much hate me say that's like don't kill
the messenger
I don't know that he's faithful I mean
nobody honestly that doesn't surprise me
absolutely nobody in Hollywood is
faithful and once I found out that I
worked Decker probably isn't faithful I
was done with oh shut up
yeah I know we just caught him I know
it's just like it's such a letdown
except why can't they be faithful and
that's what we were saying yesterday
when you get to this level of power and
money you lose touch with reality Tom
Hanks I believe never cheated on his
wife I J I kind of agreed that Dave
Matthews definitely went Dave Matthews
math you're so like Fallston in so many
ways in old think that's one of my yes
miss comes we don't talk does your
family have ticker accents than you oh
my god my dad is unintelligible and he
went to Harvard so he's smart he's like
we were dressed as a Harvard yes and
he's a doctor
what kind ophthalmologist what does that
eyes so he's an eye surgeon but he can
so he can give you LASIK and stuff
Orlin cataract surgery but he can also
give you some Botox growl do you make
him me a busy oh yeah for free what was
last time you got it um it's looking
pretty and she wants to go up to Boston
to do it well yeah but he got his
license to New York it's an open to
practice up here shut up she got a trip
yes No we'll take a trip slash he'll be
your guy when in the city that's it I'm
like I'm like planning it out when it
comes to my jawline I'm strictly sharing
jay-z but I can be open to someone else
for Botox I'm telling you it is
everything you do you care talking about
how surgeries have a couple questions
for you zero by the way the shows the
story is over so now if you're on a
Facebook YouTube feel free to flood with
comments for Taylor and I will get them
to her because unfortunately she's not
here tomorrow but I wanted to top it off
with a couple questions for you what
have you gotten done surgery was the
only not surgery like cosmetic Botox
mm-hmm how many times oh my god
countless well you didn't pull through
all this I start when I was like 18 well
when you when you want to pay for it you
know what to think about it had this
like thing it's called a hemifacial
blepharospasm
and basically I just blink a lot cuz I'm
like a spaz and I'm nervous so I would
never notice that oh my god you'll have
it Botox you probably catch it a little
bit cuz it's like when I'm on camera I'm
just like alright so that's why I do
radio but my dad started giving to me
when I was 18 for that and like I'm like
well while you're here you might as well
prevent up here so he yeah he's um he's
a master he's good he does my mom and me
but it's good just to do it at your
house no just go often yes I've been in
like the freezer yeah yeah exactly
aside from that teeth whitening right
just Botox yeah well I wanted to ask you
this yesterday I forgot about it and
what's not me a really more of a
question more of a comment because I
love watching the very few Instagram
stories that you do because I love to
shame her she did suppose more I do need
photos more I'm trying so hard I don't
know my problem is like I was even
saying today I was like so when I'm
coming on with the choice I'm like so
excited I'm hosting a bajillion times
yeah and also the graphics are amazing
so it helps but I'm like I never post
about my radio my podcast well with me I
don't know I die I have a thing with it
I have to get over maybe I should go to
therapy or you should literally just
hire someone that - free unpaid intern
we have one here right yeah should we
pay this [ __ ] she wouldn't show she's a
she would actually do an amazing job you
would let's talk let's talk but I love
like you do what I do like I don't even
take my hair down I am up with my double
chin and I love that and they don't see
anyone else who really gets up in there
internet for real you look heinous like
in a good way I mean in a good way
like heinous I love that I get I got
like I so I did a fab satsang box with
no makeup
I got destroyed by some of my listeners
they were like right cuz you're supposed
to look with that fuzz of fat and I was
like it was it was a one about a
sleeping mask who's wearing full makeup
with a sleeping man right I was all
alone and I couldn't find my [ __ ]
selfie stick and I was having a panic
attack I had no time to put makeup on no
that is so funny but is that a conscious
decision of yours when you when you
story like do you make this like do you
think I should check my hair now I am
lazy
yeah that's it same and if I have to
like think about doing it like I I'm on
content mm-hmm so if there's something
funny I want to say or share I'm like
[ __ ] how I look right because I used to
never post cuz I was always so concerned
about how I love huh which is just like
nothing right baby
yeah so totally I'm like but that's why
I posted frequently cuz sometimes like
the superficiality gets to me and then
I'm like they'll say I'm ugly like there
is this psycho fans hate page that was
like means of me I was actually
impressed and how professionally done it
was what was it called
I do not remember mind it but
it was like it had like 11 followers
you're crushing that's a lot but it was
my hey peaches 500 oh my god I know it
was so much it was not Don jealous you
know I know I'm well very I'm honestly
very proud it was it takes so much
energy and effort I'm like like it's
almost like when I'm in like a movie
when there's a murderer right has like a
scrapbook of like all of his kids right
that's what it felt like
but but when you die hate his pictures
we will find the person who has an
Instagram ham will know what's behind us
a camel toe one me and the Internet can
be well you you know what it's no
interesting you've been around the block
yeah so you were kind of involved in
this whole scene before social media was
like a big part of it totally and I just
like what was it like it was what was it
like gonna work and not having to worry
about like instagramming from work so it
was like totally liberating cuz you just
work on the work like that was thing is
I gave my soul for four hours on the air
so when when like Instagram Twitter
everything popped up I'm like I got
nothing left to give
right I'm an empty shell when I leave
the world but that's not okay any notes
or now the chef two hours so I have two
more hours to give my soul but I will
say that social media has made it
possible for people to go independent
and not have to like kowtow to the man
right so like the corporate machine
thank God for it that is so true yeah
well I can't leave I didn't tell you
this because I dropped her name off man
so I'm dead I'm dying so what happens so
I was walking obviously to get a drink
and I saw Nico Tortorella shot charlie
sauce I'm guessing his wife yes no they
don't you know he's not he and his wife
a keys anyway that's a great question
because it's just wife archiving
generate to be safe wife would be gender
her partner partner so funny enough I
didn't know that they were married and I
know her they were or weren't the work
yeah they I know that they were together
they had like a crazy alone cool wedding
yeah do you see the picture is of course
it looked gorgeous she's so skinny well
so a while back did I say the story
yesterday about shape magazine no are
you sure yeah I have dimension market I
say that she a magazine story no so like
two years
and I did a digital series with shape
magazine shot it's [ __ ] hysterical I
really just it's called fun employed and
just it's on YouTube it's so good
basically we did a couple episodes where
we tried out new trendy like workouts
that people are loving like made fun of
them I'm dead
so one of the one the ones we did was
SLT which is this Pilates [ __ ] that
Margot [ __ ] loves so hard and I'm it
was I did it like a fake version because
it was like for filming but I still to
do some of the moves and like I was
tripping with sweat I was quivering one
yet so quivering they brought like
obviously their most prestigious
instructor my name is this cutie Bethany
she had a shaved head she had a lying
tattoo starting from the side of her
body all the way down to the bottom of
her toe all the way down her side she
was so cool and edgy like I really
thought she was trying to cope with that
and I was like yes [ __ ] get it and it
was just so funny and honestly look I
don't remember any other episodes
because I have to mention but I really
remember her I was just like strep I
heard thought she was like really
interesting right and I checked out her
Instagram a couple times and then I
found out that they're [ __ ] married
it's crazy it's crazy it's crazy so I we
were like passing crossing paths and I
was like nothing and she like was so
nice and like I obviously I was like
shape magazine girls and jobless I
didn't want like forgot but she like
either she was pregnant pretending or
she actually knew him and she was so
sweet and so fun Emil it's so cold they
were like dressed up and then I was like
huh Nico we follow each other on
Instagram me and eco so I'm gonna I'm
girl to a job like we thought which
other Instagram he's like oh cool like
they were so cool and so nice oh and
then I was like I wanted to continue the
conversation but I didn't really have
anything else to say cuz like I'm
smoking something like four [ __ ]
years and I was like oh my think you
don't know is but today I'm Taylor from
you know blank tree so he was like oh no
way she's awesome
I don't know why I told ya because a lot
of people wanted to know if you were
team Josh or team Charles but we asked
Josh and I'm Josh okay but do you think
it's because he now knows who you are
well I give it answer yesterday so now
goodbye okay this question is from Emma
amen Emily Emily are you gonna be on the
season of enter from pearls at stassi's
birthday cuz you were in LA and you were
at the house so I don't know um they
asked him like me and I said no because
my friend is on the ship one of my so in
front of the bunch of the cast mates and
I also am really friendly was one of the
producers on the show and she's pretty
high up and so I knew if she was like
[ __ ] you are miked she would say it yep
and so there was somebody who's like are
you supposed to be fake and I thought if
I was like yeah I'm thirsty
and so I'm like you know what no and if
this producer wants me Mike show like
force went down my throat but how was
the birthday but it was Ariana and
stassi's shared about you know what's so
weird and I don't mean to like totally
ruin party scenes for anybody and this
is the same for like scripted it doesn't
matter but any party scene that you see
there is no music shook so have you ever
gone to a musical Esparta cut that is so
awkward because like we were like
partying like tights before and like
bonding and hanging out and then they're
like okay like it's just now because
we're have the the music list party and
like sometimes they'll play like
elevator music in the background yeah
well I never thought of that there's no
music because it's so awkward because
they're filming in a there are different
lyrics they can't cut right and it's
like a copyright thing yes so anyway so
it's it's weird cuz it's quiet but I
forgot that just cuz I don't have a
microphone other people's microphones
pick up your voice yes like we can hear
Margo right now even the snow Morgan
mice so I had a conversation with
stassi's mom about stuff oh [ __ ] and I'm
like I listen if it makes it it makes it
it might have had something to do with
Patrick her ex-boyfriend and he is still
a friend of mine what am i definitely I
am I am in contact with Stassi more
right and that's just cuz probably were
girls and yes like I'm owed the same way
and he doesn't really want to talk about
stuff and I respect that but like I was
just talking to her mom about like how
things were and like where she's now
with beau you know cuz I mean her new
boyfriend oh great I don't even know him
but I love him amazing yeah I love him
so I'm I kinda remember what I said but
I'm not really some like that I could
see maybe Louisville thing you were on
an episode of summer house lesbian
lesbian right straight stream so you
were with a meat a meat and you and
Taylor went to a party yep cuz you're
friendly with Stephen yes who's no
longer on the show yes and you were
miked or no I was not my again but see
but you were talking really closely to
someone wearing a mic but that's the
thing it's crazy because even if there's
not a camera around you could still be
getting picked up and that's it's like
because they've like hidden cameras it's
like big brother well they had like Big
Brother cameras there yeah yeah then I
don't think Vanderpump has that no
because we don't all live in the same
house no but um
Oh duh right so I'm like but um yeah so
a meet-up welded here to happen was a
meet Taylor and I were just hanging out
so we went and did this scene with
Stephen for 45 minutes I was sweating
profusely I was so nervous my god
furniture it was torch it was torture
and then I took my mic off and then we
were done and he's like you neck so I
was like hanging and drinking and like I
can [ __ ] up to my getting around
cameras is so dangerous it's so
dangerous and so Taylor and I like gave
each other kiss and we were up on the
balcony like judging I remember I
remember
and a meet came over and he grabbed us
this is on camera and he pushed us up
against the wall
he said do it again do it again do it
again do it again and I said get the
[ __ ] away nice yas me too he's not on it
no he's not on the show anymore oh [ __ ]
threw a drink at him good the second the
drinks out of my hand and he's like what
the [ __ ] the cameras are running and I'm
like no no no no no no cuz I'm now drunk
yeah I'm gonna look like the crazy girl
is trying to get attention yeah and so I
was then trying to like before the
cameras came I was like yo yo be cool
you deserve it that yo yo we cool I
don't really go we're leaving for person
I'm a become like a man and I was like
it's all good it's all good like like I
was like you deserve that we're good
right he was like yeah and then he just
starting to get it and he was like fine
now cameras are up there and that's when
he said I like your eyes so he's hidden
on us again
oh yeah and so I'm like koala bear
e-tailer yeah like a loser I look like a
full-blown no and he's like I said she's
like a lesbian lesbian one no like no
registrants cuz I'm all drawn right and
then he says I'm a straight straight
which is funny and then Taylor says you
look like a lesbian
you with the beard oh man what a little
[ __ ] what a [ __ ] bag right oh my god I
didn't know that I think that's how that
happened I knew they were drinking it
but I didn't know which the whole thing
was actually went down here because you
come out the hero right Wow
LGBTQ champion totally yeah you'd be at
the face of like every campaign or if
they caught it I just be the thirstiest
[ __ ] yeah then you'd like be thrown in
prison
exactly honestly I don't want the show
to end cuz that means like our time up
is together cuz you're not here tomorrow
but honestly love co-hosting with you if
you subscribe to till the show I was on
yesterday and I was on it this morning
as well to really fun about half-hour
segments each at the end first one is a
little bit more serious if you're into
that second one is a little bit lighter
if
not a subscriber what is it a month
$6.95 why do that number because that's
some of my partners came up with that
Lexus 99 I don't get all that just so
you guys know 695 a month and you do
daily morning show 8 to 10 so you can
still watch the the toast and yeah no
particular anymore it's the Taylor show
and they own the trademark is that why I
own the trademark to tell strikers wake
up with Taylor Oh serious yeah so yeah
you can do that's what we had with
breath and then if you don't want to pay
which I totally respect and get just
listen to taste of Taylor podcast every
Wednesday and this Wednesday is my
serious hour serious Claudia interview
for lack of a better word are serious
and I really are I oh yeah it's really
good I think and a lot of you been
asking a bunch of questions about like
kind of our time off and I've kind of
been like just pushing it off because
like it I never know like how to do it
and I get like super uncomfortable but
talking about of a Taylor I was like so
easy honestly I was like I need to stop
talking because I'm like saying way too
much because Taylor just like she opens
me up literally and it's Alyssa and it's
really great so that's taste of Taylor
podcast it'll be out tomorrow tomorrow I
believe we're gonna have been I'll fine
pending his schedule we just got like a
lot of requests for it and honestly I've
watched him when he was on with Jackie
and like I was getting so mad cuz he was
like telling stories about us and he's
so jolly so he lies like I have to write
all the wrong so he was telling stories
that he said Claudia does this I'm like
that's not what happened
oh so I had a lot of Corrections to make
tomorrow and then Thursday the points
guys here where we're gonna recap all
the VMAs stuff there
Grande stuff he's great I'm gonna do a
master post in our morning Chester's
Facebook group because a lot of you guys
have kind of specific questions for him
about like what credit cards to use
about the best airline like best
practices and we're gonna get down to
basic journey like hardcore specific
questions so I will do a master post
Thursday night I'm in Hasbrouck Heights
New Jersey at two shows I believe that
they're sold out I do think that the
second show has like a couple VIP
tickets left if you want to come and
meet and greet and get a front-row seat
and get there early for drinks that is
ideal girl no job calm and then Friday
we're off because I feel like I will
have had a long week by Thursday yeah
and I just know myself you know do you
ever take Friday's off yes all the time
do you have to you have to take your
vacation days because if you don't you
actually are less productive and
more susceptible to like sickness yes
when you cancel a show like how much
noticed you give so I've had so six
months I started I took one sick day
that was like a best-of which I like try
not to do but what I do do but I've
taken I've been so sick like the last
whatever so I have my co-host go on live
without me
Oh which is good that's so funny we
literally like we've been doing the show
for three months I'm like we are always
taking these off
but like heaven but you guys can't cuz
you're yeah you're a duo right weird
that's true yeah it's nice I'm sorry to
hold down the fort or I like I do pre
records like today when I scoot
laterally we had 30 yeah do you um [ __ ]
was I gonna say to would you ever do
like a show that had like another
co-host on you like being in charge I
would do what I would do another co-host
show I worked with my co-host a serious
Kenny for eight years and I loved it
I just after him it was like impossible
to replace him cuz audience was so
obsessed with the two of us anybody was
gonna get totally screwed so we did the
rotation just to kind of like like ease
people into the change yeah and then I
was like the rotations kind of great
because it like frees me up to like be a
different me yeah every single day so I
like that but I would so do a co-host to
thank town so interesting well thank you
so much for being here till his tractor
you could follow her at Telus wrecker or
if you want to subscribe which you
should the [ __ ] was great and listen all
the time Telstra even though I pay like
a normal person I don't get like a
discount or anything um tell us - I pay
for my I do do because my free one
doesn't like access the way audience
that's all need to see from their
perspective that is so Taylor trekker
calm co-star gonna come um thank you
guys so much for watching the money on
morning show the morning trust me go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time every day we go live on
Facebook and YouTube so make sure to
subscribe to us there but if you're a
commuter you just love to podcast and
listen to people COFF
make sure to check out the Apple iTunes
Store
what does it called the podcast store at
the morning shows but if you've an
Android we're also available in
SoundCloud coming to Spotify very soon
thank you guys so much for being here
and it's been an absolute pleasure I
think you Taylor for being here we will
see you tomorrow with then hopefully
you